[Música]
después de la elección presidencial que
tuvo lugar en francia el pasado 24 abril
de este año cuyo resultado confirmó la
victoria del presidente emmanuel macrón
la ciudadanía ahora se prepara para
acudir nuevamente a las urnas esta vez
para renovar la asamblea nacional
compuesta por
577 diputados la primera vuelta de esa
elección legislativa se va a llevar a
cabo este próximo domingo 12 de junio
mientras que la segunda será el 19 de
este mismo mes el líder del movimiento
de la francia en su mesa jean-luc
mélenchon le pide el voto ciudadano para
así convertirse en primer ministro por
medio de la consecuencia la consecución
de la mayoría de la asamblea nacional a
este escenario se le conoce como en
francia como la cohabitación política
esto limitaría el margen de maniobra del
presidente macrón el cual ya no podría
apoyarse en su primer ministro para
llevar a cabo su programa de este
segundo gobierno saludamos entonces a
nuestro segundo invitado al día de la
flor en la farsa analista y ex consejero
del palacio del elíseo florian gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 muy buena mañana se
necesitan entonces doscientos ochenta y
nueve diputados para así obtener la
mayoría absoluta que tan lejos o tan
cerca está el partido de macrón de
lograrlo
bueno claramente hay una dinámica que
está debilitada para él esa consecuencia
sea de su ausencia durante esta campaña
claramente el macro nismo no hizo
campaña fue pasivo un poco como lo ha
hecho durante las presidenciales él
pensaba que era una estrategia muy buena
para eso justamente porque pensaba que
iba a aprovechar la dinámica de las
presidenciales para ganar las
legislativas pero hay que reconocer que
me la acción fue más inteligente
estratégicamente porque ha ocupando todo
el espacio mediático de esta campaña y
obviamente él tiene una dinámica mucho
más favorable una dinámica que depende
de la creación de su alianza de la
izquierda
precisamente hablando de la izquierda
como llega este movimiento político
digamos de todas las izquierdas a
unidades en francia a estas primeras
legislativas digamos la primera vuelta
este próximo domingo 12 no y también le
quiero preguntar si realmente me
decisión tendría el chance de
convertirse en el primer ministro como
él lo afirma
bueno él está en una dinámica que es muy
positiva y ha ganado según los sondeos
entre 50 y 70 colores más pero esos
sondeos que no pueden ser tomado como
serios porque dependen por mucho de la
capacidad de cada partido de movilizar
en una elección que está conocida por
alta atención
sobre todo se trata de
577 curules son como
577 curules pequeñas elecciones
presidenciales con contextos locales y
dinámicas muy distintas pero hay muchos
limitantes para mí la opción de ganar
esta dirección primero su propia imagen
en estilo la dureza de sus posiciones
políticas y económicas son posiciones
que son muy relevantes no tiene como
consecuencia lógica que los franceses no
lo ven como un árbitro nacional que
puede tomar la altura sobre los desafíos
de los próximos años en la segunda razón
es su dinámica electoral el hecho que
tiene una dinámica muy
y puede generar una nueva dinámica de
sus adversarios los cuales van a
movilizarse para impedirle una mayoría
en la asamblea en la tercera razón es el
problema de tener una alianza el ámbito
toda la izquierda en un solo polo a
nivel nacional la unión favorece la nube
ese es el nombre de esta alianza que un
ex socialista ecologistas y comunistas
pero es favorable porque evita una
división teórica del voto de izquierda
la primera vuelta la realidad es que
para ganar
hay que tener una reserva de votos para
la segunda vuelta haciendo esta alianza
la nube es la alianza es fuerte en la
primera vuelta pero sin dinámica posible
en la segunda por falta de reserva de
votos y la última razón que es limitante
para menos o es la geografía del voto
aquí claramente hay un límite porque me
lo mostró tiene un voto que es muy
concentrado en algunas regiones de
francia de hecho durante las
presidenciales en
290 circunscripciones me lanzó no
alcanzó el 20 por ciento de los votos lo
que un factor limitante para ganar estas
elecciones estamos hablando de la
izquierda de esta gran coalición de las
izquierdas en francia nos vamos al otro
polo hablamos de la extrema derecha
aumentará la participación en asamblea
nacional francesa la extrema derecha
además habrá de penn impulsada por se
move
y bueno
literalmente se ha hecho una una
dinámica hacia la extrema derecha
pero no creo que vayan a tener muchos
colores dentro de la asamblea nacional
porque es un partido que es nuevo no va
a lograr reunir justamente el
suficientemente votos para alcanzar la
segunda vuelta y tampoco para imaginar
la imagen de pena es más interesante
porque de hecho es el gran fantasma de
esta elección imagine pena está
totalmente ausente de esta dirección no
hay estrategia de la extrema derecha no
ha presentado candidatos de buena
calidad lo que ha implicado justamente
una de credibilidad en un poco de este
partido para estar esta dirección
elección que de toda forma de lucha ha
favorecido los extremos entonces la
extrema derecha claramente va a tener un
poco más de curules de lo que habría
tenido durante la dirección de 2017 pero
sin ser un partido de mayor importancia
en la asamblea nacional
porque esta desaparición digamos de
alguna manera de lepe en esta campaña
para las legislativas
no hay
realmente ella ha tomado vacaciones este
año un poco de la política francesa
seguramente para descansar te de las
elecciones presidenciales porque es algo
que es muy cansador que es muy
importante pero a la de esto que me
sorprende a mí es ver que su propio
partido él no había preparado estas
elecciones lo único que sí había
preparado es la nominación de los
diferentes candidatos en las 577 y
circunscripciones porque es importante
esto nombrar a todos los candidatos en
todas las circos que chávez es porque la
asamblea nacional estas legislativas es
un poco la caja fuerte de los partidos
políticos es con esta elección que van a
ganar en euros van a ganar dinero por
presentar a candidatos cada voto es un
punto treinta euros más o menos si le
presentan 50 candidatos a nivel nacional
entonces es importante financieramente
hablando claro y luego de estas
elecciones figuran ya para finalizar
nuestra conversación podría el
presidente manuel macro en gobernar sin
problema en estos cinco años que ya le
quedan por delante
si la quinta república es la república
que es la más suave es decir que uno se
puede muy bien adaptar es una república
un agilizada la cosa es que es
dependiendo a ver cuántos cuantos
diputados va a tener si él tiene la
mayoría absoluta claramente él va a
poder hacerlo de lo que quiera al pitar
su programa como previsto si no la tiene
va a tener que negociar unas alianzas
alianzas quizás temporales según los
proyectos de leyes con otros partidos
para justamente lograr conseguir al
pasar estas leyes y sí pero es muy poco
probable si miramos o gana estas
elecciones entonces ahí él va a imponer
la cohabitación el caso es tal vez sin
macro en baile hill melón son como
primer ministro no legalmente en la
constitución el presidente puede elegir
cualquier persona como el primer
ministro pero hay también tradiciones y
la tradición 3d que enormemente el
presidente toma en cuenta los resultados
y las legislativas para nombrar
justamente la persona que es el líder de
este partido de la formación política
que ha ganado la selección la tradición
pero no la ley digamos que elisabeth por
entonces se podría quedar sin macro un
asilo de sigue en el cargo de primera
ministra no
si podría pero no con una familia que
sería miran sionistas porque los
milanistas no van a votar la confianza
de esta primera ministra y esto
impondría el matrón de nombrar un primer
ministro que sería a favor de la nubes
centro federal ya la izquierda